[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regarder
les jt mondial sur rt france au sommaire
aujourd'hui la bolivie la démission
brutale du président socialiste evo
morales a bouleversé le fonctionnement
de tout le pays des changements profonds
s'opère en interne comme à
l'international
alors où en est-on actuellement dans
cette crise politique et sociale qui
tourmentent la bolivie exilé depuis plus
d'un mois en argentine l'ancien
président bolivien evo morales qui
n'abandonne pas le combat politique en
décembre 2019
il se dit prêt à revenir en bolivie une
déclaration qui fait suite à la
nomination de morales en tant que chef
de campagne électorale de son parti le
mouvement vers le socialisme en signe de
soutien à morales ses partisans
continuent à protester contre la prise
du pouvoir par la sénatrice de droite
jeanine agnès cette dernière
autoproclamé présidente par intérim en
novembre est vue comme la figure de
proue d'un coup d'état par la gauche
bolivienne
ces bouleversements internes n'ont pas
manqué d'attirer l'attention de la
communauté internationale les pays
socialistes de la région par le aussi
d'un coup d'état avec condamne les
violences de la part des nouvelles
autorités
une position antagonistes et défendue
par les états unis et le brésil qui
tendent la main à la nouvelle chef
d'état depuis son accession au pouvoir
[Musique]
mais avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il
faut savoir sur les premiers pas du
nouveau gouvernement bolivien
c'est le blitz le 12 novembre jannier
agnel se proclame présidente et procède
ensuite à la formation du gouvernement
composé majoritairement de la droite
bolivienne le nouveau cabinet adopte une
ligne ferme à l'égard de l'ancien
président evo morales et ses anciens
collaborateurs près de 600 d'entre eux
font actuellement l'objet de poursuites
judiciaires
à l'international le nouveau
gouvernement abandonne la ligne
politique de morales les relations
diplomatiques avec le venezuela sont
rompues un coup dur est porté aux
relations avec cuba et des centaines de
médecins et d'enseignants cuba quittent
le pays
enfin en scandale diplomatique éclate
avec le mexique
les résultats l'ambassadeur mexicain est
renvoyé chez lui
parallèlement l'amélioration des
relations se profile avec le brésil la
diplomatie brésilienne a été parmi les
premières à féliciter la nouvelle chef
d'état donald trump lui aussi tend la
main à l'ancienne sénatrice de droite et
autorise l'octroi d'une aide financière
à la bolivie
la bolivie est plongée dans l'inconnu
depuis la démission du président
socialiste evo morales accusé par
l'opposition de fraude électorale
ils quittent le pays en laissant le
siège présidentiel libre le vide du
pouvoir est comblé par la deuxième
vice-présidente du sénat jeanine agnès
qui se proclament présidente par intérim
à peine pris les rênes du pays et elle
entame un virage à droite
parmi ses premières actions figurent la
nomination du nouveau gouvernement qui
veut avant tout en finir avec l'héritage
de morales des centaines de ses anciens
collaborateurs sont menacés de
poursuites judiciaires
le mouvement vers le socialisme le parti
de morales pourraient être privés du
droit de participer aux nouvelles
élections générales prévues en mai 2020
à l'international la ligne politique de
morales semble abandonné le nouveau
gouvernement rompt les relations avec le
venezuela se distancie de cuba et se
fâche avec le mexique
au contraire un rapprochement se dessine
avec le brésil et les etats-unis les
deux pays ont été parmi les premiers à
reconnaître la nouvelle présidente par
intérim bolivienne comment explique-t-il
leur décision qu'est ce qui a déclenché
la démission de morales enfin comment
le parti de l'ancien président
socialiste compte il lutter pour
reconquérir le pouvoir
pour répondre à ces questions nous
rejoignons christine delfour professeur
des universités à l'université paris-est
marne-la-vallée spécialiste de
l'amérique latine et particulièrement de
la bolivie
madame delfour bonjour un bon jour alors
il ya beaucoup de discussions sur ce qui
s'est passé en novembre en bolivie la
prise de pouvoir par l'opposition était
légitime ou est ce un coup d'état
véritablement selon non ce n'est pas un
coup d'état
ce n'est pas un coup d'état tout
simplement parce que monsieur morales
est parti de son propre chef
deuxièmement l'armée n'a pas occupé tout
de suite les instances le palais du
gouvernement et il n'a pas nommé une
jatte militaire donc on ne peut pas dire
que c'est un coup d'état
malgré certaines gouvernements en
particulier le gouvernement mexicain
moment donné qui a qui a parlé d'un coup
d'état mais surtout evo morales qui a
parlé d'un coup d'état ce n'est pas un
coup d'état
c'est une évidence et d'ailleurs
récemment evo morales a reconnu qu' il
avait donné sa démission quelques heures
avant que le
général des forces armées et le lui ai
suggéré
donc ce n'est pas un coup d'état donc
quelle est la raison selon vous de
l'échec de morales pourquoi même l armée
la police sont elle rejoint les
manifestants en fin de compte
et bien qu écouter eux cela remonte
quand même à 2016
au moment où evo morales a décidé
d'organiser un référendum pour lui
permettre de se représenter aux
élections en 2019 alors que la
constitution ne lui permettait pas
puisque il y en en principe la
possibilité d'avoir deux mandats et pas
plus de deux mandats de quatre ans donc
le résultat de ceux de ce référendum
aa et d'une certaine manière à démontrer
à evo morales que la majorité de la
population était contre le fait d'une un
troisième mandat d'une nouvelle règle
d'une d'un changement de la constitution
à partir de ce moment là evo morales et
son gouvernement ont essayé de forcer si
vous voulez les choses le processus
démocratique et aux élections d'octobre
2010 9
la population a bien évidemment voté en
grande partie contre si vous voulez le
ce cette volonté de de ne pas de se
représenter d'evo morales evo morales
n'a pas écouté la clameur populaire et
même si il a un socle important il ya
environ 25-30 % de la population qui
adhère aux masses donc là simplement la
population désire est un processus
démocratique normal et a démontré
qu'elle avait une culture politique
démocratique
ce que son président ne semble pas avoir
en tout cas c'est ce qui s'est passé
quant à alarmer
si vous voulez la police était depuis un
moment mais contente avec le
gouvernement pour des raisons de salaire
il y avait il y avait vraiment un de
tension très forte entre le gouvernement
et la police et ce mécontentement qui
était latent s'est déclarée s'est
manifesté lors de de cette période assez
assez durs des élections et de
l'incapacité de evo morales à vouloir
organiser un second tour qui semblait
être
possible puisqu'il n'avait pas la
majorité des voix au premier tour
quant à l'armée si vous voulez au bout
d'un moment l'armée a s'est rendu compte
que les choses n'allaient pas donc lui
ont demandé de de partir mais l'armée
constitutionnaliste puisqu'elle à
respecter la constitution
elle est restée si vous voulez dans le
cadre de la constitution
il a plus aucun soutien de l'armée
morales il doit en avoir toujours des
soutiens sûrement comme il doit avoir
des il a des soutiens mais il doit avoir
des soutiens d'alarmé sage l'ignorent
mais l'armée mais l'armée est
fondamentalement constitutionnaliste ce
qui est à souligner dans un pays où il
ya eu énormément de coups d'état ou
cours de l'histoire et où souvent
l'armée a pris le pouvoir
or une fois on a une armée
constitutionnaliste donc
donc voila mais je pense qu'au niveau
personnel
il se peut qu'il y ait des des
militaires qui est qui qui soit proche
du mas de toute façon du mouvement vers
le socialisme qui est le parti d'evo
morales en particulier des cadres de
l'armée
mais je répète elle elle est
démocratique
merci beaucoup madame delfour nous
allons poursuivre notre analyse tout de
suite mais nous retrouverons en fin
d'émission pour plus de détails sur la
question
l'ex président bolivien evo morales fait
une tentative pour s'accrocher au
pouvoir depuis son exil le 13 janvier
2020 à buenos aires ils lancent un appel
à la création de milices populaires dans
le pays
quelques jours plus tard morales renonce
à cette idée mais celle ci s'est déjà
répondu en bolivie et dans le monde
entier
si d'ici peu si je devais rentrer ou si
quelqu'un y retourne
nous devons organiser comme au venezuela
des milices armées dans le peuple
nous étions trop confiant erreur
colossale et que nous n'avions pas de
plan b
cette erreur est donc survenu en
novembre 2019 lors des bouleversements
internes que l'ancien président bolivien
qualifie de coup d'état
tout commence par la tenue des élections
présidentielles le 20 octobre après le
dépouillement d'environ 84% des
bulletins
le chef de l'état socialiste est en tête
avec 45 points 71 % des voix suivi par
le centriste carlos mesa avec 37 points
4 24% des votes
un second tour devait donc avoir lieu
soudain le décompte est interrompue la
pause dure un jour est la reprise du
dépouillement bonne finalement un
avantage de plus de 10% à evo morales
soit un écart suffisant pour éviter un
second tour
un vrai coup de tonnerre pour
l'opposition qui s'empresse de dénoncer
la fraude électorale en appelant à la
grève illimitée le 25 octobre
les résultats définitifs sont annoncés
morales est officiellement proclamé
vainqueur
en réponse l'opposition appelle à
renforcer la pression des dizaines de
milliers de personnes descendent dans la
rue en accusant morales de fraudes
électorales blocage des roues grèves des
manifestations qui débouchent sur des
violences
le chaos s'installe dans le pays face à
l'aggravation de la crise politique
evo morales invite l'organisation des
états américains à procéder à un audit
électorale le 10 novembre
coup de théâtre les observateurs de
l'oéa affirme avoir révélé des
irrégularités dans le décompte des voix
une déclaration qui jettent de l'huile
sur le feu provoquant la colère de la
rue
la police et les militaires se joignent
aux manifestants
et demande à morales de démissionner
privé de son appui principal le
président bolivien fait le choix de se
retirer
à peine cette décision prise et morales
se réfugie au mexique puis en argentine
ses alliés le vice-président le
président du sénat est celui de la
chambre des députés se dépêchent eux
aussi de faire leurs valises
le 12 novembre profitant de la vacance
du pouvoir janina niaise la deuxième
vice président du sénat opposante
farouche de morales ce programme
présidente par intérim
j'ai su immédiatement la présidence de
l'état qui est inscrite dans l'ordre
constitutionnel et je m'engage à assumer
toutes les mesures nécessaires pour
pacifier le pays
sans trop tarder jeanine agnès
commencent à redresser complètement le
paysage politique du pays
parmi ses premières actions la
nomination du gouvernement par intérim
le 13 novembre le nouveau cabinet est
présenté aux boliviens
ses membres sont presque tous issus de
la droite bolivienne qui ne cache pas
son intention d'en terminer avec
l'héritage d'evo morales à peine investi
le nouveau ministre de l'intérieur pour
faute d'un prisonnier l'ancien président
à perpétuité des actions qui sont
accueillis à bras ouverts par les
manifestants anti morales or le calme
n'est toujours pas rétabli et après
l'arrivée d'agnès au pouvoir c'est au
tour des partisans de morales de
descendre dans la rue le 13 novembre
plusieurs organisations indigènes
ouvriers et paysannes déclare une grève
générale illimitée des milliers de
personnes installent des barrages
routiers à la passe en exigeant le
départ de la présidente intérimaire sur
fond d'une escalade de tension janina
niaise adopte un décret qualifié par la
presse locale de décret de mort ce
document dégagent les forces armées et
la police nationale de toutes
responsabilités pénales liées à l' usage
de la force contre les manifestants
résultat les violences prennent une
nouvelle tournure et se propage dans
tout le pays bilan des dizaines de morts
plus d'une centaine de blessés
immédiatement la situation attire les
regards de la communauté internationale
l'onu ne tarde pas à condamner les
actions du nouveau gouvernement qu'elle
qualifie de répressions
le pays est divisé et les gens des deux
côtés du clivage
politiques sont extrêmement en colère
les actions répressives des autorités ne
feront qu'attiser encore davantage cette
colère et risque de compromettre toute
possibilité de dialoguer fin novembre le
décret controversé et pourtant annulé
cependant les manifestations ont pris
beaucoup d'élan le chemin vers la sortie
de crise pourrait s'ouvrir avec de
nouvelles élections présidentielle et
législatives prévues pour mai 2020 le 24
novembre une loi convoquant le scrutin
et promulguer ce texte interdit à toute
personne ayant exercé deux mandats de
suite de se présenter à un troisième
une disposition qui barre la route à la
candidature d'evo morales aux prochaines
élections l'ancien président est déjà
désigné début décembre chef de campagne
de son parti le mas cependant
reviendra-t-il dans le pays compte tenu
de la position intransigeante de la
nouvelle chef de l'état un délit
électoral est en cours et si le
président morales vient à la
confrontation il se confrontera à la
justice bolivienne morales n'est
pourtant pas le seul dans le viseur du
nouveau gouvernement les accusations
septembre également sur ses anciens
collaborateurs
près de 600 personnes considérées comme
proches de morales font actuellement
l'objet de poursuites judiciaires
parmi elles les responsables
d'entreprises publiques et d'anciens
membres du gouvernement les menaces
pèsent également sur le parti de morales
qui pourraient être privés du droit de
participer aux prochaines élections le
tribunal devra décider si le mas
participe à nouveau où nous le président
morales et le mas voulait passer en
force au moyen de fraude électorale
c'est une infraction pénale
face à ces déclarations le parti de
morales ne baisse pas les bras et
entament les préparatifs pour la
nouvelle campagne électorale qui est
actuellement le favori des sondages
comment la communauté internationale
réagit tel événement en bolelli enfin
comment le nouveau gouvernement change
tic de cap à l'international
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
la tension va donc crescendo en bolivie
après avoir pris les rênes du pays le
nouveau gouvernement de droite adopte
une ligne dure à l'égard de l'ex
président evo morales icône de la gauche
bolivienne il a complètement changé le
pays durant ses 14 ans au pouvoir
d'abord syndicalistes et défenseurs de
la culture de la coca evo morales se
lance en politique dans les années 90
fervent socialistes ils accèdent aux
postes de membres de parlement bolivien
en 1997 et ensuite devient une figure
majeure du parti mouvement vers le
socialisme dans un contexte politique
tendu morales se présente aux élections
présidentielles de 2002 mais arrive en
deuxième place avec 20 % des suffrages
entre 2002 et 2005 la bolivie est
touchée par une crise économique et
sociale qui donne lieu à une succession
de président en 2005 lors des élections
présidentielles morales se présente
alors comme une alternative aux
gouvernements néolibéraux précédent il
veut être le défenseur des amérindiens
délaissé selon lui par les gouvernements
précédents
les amérindiens représente alors 60 % de
la population totale de bolivie morales
remporte les élections présidentielles
et devient en 2006 le premier amérindien
à occuper ce poste
dès sa prise de fonction il promet de
lutter contre la corruption et de sortir
le pays de la pauvreté en utilisant les
ressources naturelles tout en défendant
l'environnement et les droits des
indigènes
en effet il nationalise les usines
d'hydrocarbures jusqu'ici sous le
contrôle de compagnies étrangères est
investi dans des programmes sociaux
lors de son premier mandat le taux de
pauvreté passe de 32,4 à 24,6 pour cent
selon la banque mondiale
quelques mois avant les élections
présidentielles en février 2009 evo
morales fait adopter une nouvelle
constitution majoritairement approuvé
par la population indigène
elle autorise morales à briguer de
nouveaux mandats consécutifs
cette constitution accorde aussi
meilleure représentation aux indigènes
au congrès ainsi en décembre 2009 lors
des élections présidentielles evo
morales est réélu président avec 64% des
voix
néanmoins 2011 evo morales va à
l'encontre de sa politique aux
environnementalistes son gouvernement
envisage de construire une autoroute
traversant une réserve amazonienne
protéger des milliers de personnes
manifestent contre ce projet de loi
face à l'ampleur de la grogne le
gouvernement fait marche arrière
dès lors morales commence à perdre le
soutien de la population indigène celle
qui avait largement contribué à son
ascension au pouvoir
il sera tout de même réélu président en
2014 et ce grâce à l'amélioration
considérable de la qualité de vie des
boliviens
le taux de chômage devient l'un des plus
faibles d'amérique du sud avec près de
4% de la population active
le revenu par habitant est multiplié par
deux passant de 1000 20 dollars par an
en 2005 à 2590 dollars en 2013 selon la
banque mondiale en 2016 evo morales
connaît son premier échec politique
lorsqu'il organise un référendum afin de
faire modifier la constitution pour lui
permettre de briguer un quatrième mandat
en 2019 au même moment morales est
impliqué dans des affaires de corruption
même si morales est innocenté par la
justice bolivian il perd la confiance de
son peuple
les boliviens répondent non et rejette
l'idée d'un changement de la
constitution à près de 51 %
cependant en novembre 2010 est la cour
constitutionnelle bolivian met fin à la
limitation du nombre de mandats
présidentiels et morales se présente aux
élections de 2010 9
sans surprise les événements en bolivie
et la démission de morales suscite des
réactions fortes à l'international les
pays de gauche de l'amérique latine
dénoncent ce qu'ils voient comme un coup
d'état orchestré par l'armée une
opération militaire est en cours en
bolivie nous la condamnons cela
ressemble aux événements tragiques qui
ont ensanglanté l'amérique latine
pendant le siècle précédent
le mexique maintient sa position de
respect de la démocratie et des
institutions non au coup d'état
une opinion partagée par cuba le
venezuela l argentine tous sont
préoccupés par la violence contre les
civils et la pression de l'armée qui a
poussé morales à la démission les
déclarations sont aussitôt suivi par des
actions concrètes démissionnaire evo
morales se réfugie d'abord au mexique
puis à cuba puis finalement en argentine
qui lui accorde l'asile rapidement evo
morales et soutenu jusqu en outre
atlantique car moscou et madrid n'ont
pas tardé à réagir
l'espagne condamne le fait que le
processus ouvert en vue de la
convocation d'élections a été biaisé par
l'intervention des forces armées et de
la police qui ont demandé à evo morales
de présenter sa démission
en dehors de l'amérique latine ces
réactions restent pourtant isolé
la france par exemple est la diplomatie
européenne se sont contentés d'appeler
les parties à la retenue
pourtant à l'international le nouveau
gouvernement bolivien opère vite des
changements
la première volte-face concerne le
venezuela le 15 novembre la diplomatie
bolivienne annonce la rupture des
relations diplomatiques avec caracas et
renvoie tous les diplomates vénézuéliens
le parquet réclame aussi le gel de tous
les comptes de la paix dvs à la société
pétrolière vénézuélienne la passe
soupçonne qu'elle est utilisée pour
financer secrètement le parti de morales
masse et accuse caracas d'ingérence
histoire similaire avec cuba en novembre
la police bolivienne découvre des fonds
qui auraient été envoyés aux masses par
la havane
résultat la coopération ohkubo
bolivienne est révisée 725 médecins et
enseignants cubains travaillant en
bolivie rentrer chez eux
pire encore après un tweet virulent du
chef de la diplomatie cubaine la passe
suspend les relations diplomatiques avec
la havane
autre mesure de la bolivie la diffusion
des chaînes de télévision télé sur
vénézuélien et de rt en espagnol est
suspendu
pourtant la rupture la plus marquante
s'opère avec le mexique premier asile
d'evo morales mexico accueil toujours
une dizaine de membres de l'ancienne
administration dans ces quartiers
diplomatique en bolivie ce qui n'est pas
du tout du goût du gouvernement
intérimaire bolivien depuis l'octroi de
l'asile la police bolivienne maintient
d'ailleurs une présence autour de la
résidence diplomatique mexicaine le 27
décembre
elle empêche l'entrée de personnes
accompagnant une diplomate espagnole
selon là passe il s'agissait de
tentatives d'exfiltration ministre du
gouvernement de morales conséquence
l'ambassadeur mexicain et deux
diplomates espagnols sont renvoyés de la
police d'un point de vue plus politique
la bolivie opère en tout cas en tournant
à droite pendant sa première semaine au
pouvoir le gouvernement intérimaire
annonce la sortie du pays de l'alliance
politique et économique
alba fondée par hugo chavez et fidel
castro elle était conçue en opposition à
l' influence américaine sur le continent
la passe envisage également la sortie de
l'unasur en bloc régional inclusive qui
réunit des gouvernements des deux côtés
et du spectre politique
enfin la diplomatie boulet vienne
menacent de sortir de la celac la
communauté des états latino américains
et des caraïbes
à cause de l'attitude hostile de son
président le mexique la celac est
d'ailleurs considérée comme une
alternative à l'organisation des états
américains dominés par washington
cependant si caracas mexico et même
moscou déplore la perte d'un allié dans
la région washington ou encore brasilia
se réjouissent de ces évolutions le
gouvernement brésilien salue la
sénatrice jeanine agnès pour son
accession conformément à la constitution
au poste de président bolivien
le brésil souhaite approfondir son
amitié fraternelle avec la bolivie
nous soutenons jeanine agnès en bolivie
qui travaille pour assurer une
transition pacifique et démocratique
vers des élections libres
nous condamnons la violence et ceux qui
la provoquent depuis la bolivie et
depuis l'extérieur et ce soutien ferme
des états unis et au nouveau
gouvernement est déjà en passe de se
concrétiser
donald trump a en effet autorisé
l'octroi d'une aide financière à la
bolivie en 2020 et selon l'ancien
président evo morales cela n'aurait
qu'une explication
washington est impliqué dans sa
destitution le soutien de trump à agnès
est une nouvelle preuve que les états
unis ont organisé le coup d'état en
bolivie pourtant si le nouveau
gouvernement bolivien a déjà montré
qu'il serait à un allié fidèle de
washington un nouveau président sera élu
le 3 mai 2020 et là tout peut à nouveau
changer car le duo présidentiel choisi
par le parti d'evo morales le mas a
toutes les chances de gagner la
présidentielle 2020 le principal
candidat est luis arce et ancien
ministre de l'économie responsable du
miracle économique bolivien de la
présidence de morales son probable futur
vice président david choquehuanca est un
ancien ministre de la diplomatie
un indien aymara et vétérans de la lutte
pour les droits des indigènes et même
avant l'annoncé des candidats concret
l'opinion était déjà favorable aux
masses 20,7 pour cent des électeurs
seraient prêts à voter pour son
représentant contre 15,6 pour cent
pour janine agnès est 13,8 pour cent
pour carlos mesa le revirement
spectaculaire bolivien à l'international
va-t-il donc durer le nouveau
gouvernement laissera t-il
mas participer à l'élection face aux
sondages défavorables
que feront les états unis si les
socialistes reviennent au pouvoir pour
répondre à ces questions nous rejoignons
à nouveau christine delfour professeur
des universités à l'université paris est
marne la vallée spécialiste de
l'amérique latine et particulièrement de
la baule et madame delfour evo morales
accuse les états unis d'avoir orchestré
un coup d'état
pensez vous qu'il est partiellement
raison où cette version reste elle
encore à prouver
écoutez cette version reste toujours à
prouver
alors il est bien évidemment il est
évident que les états unis ont toujours
un oeil sur l'amérique latine et plus
qu'un oeil puisqu'il ondes et ils ont
les bases militaires en colombie puis au
paraguay que le gouvernement d'evo
morales était un gouvernement de gauche
proche du gouvernement
cuba venezuela liens et donc
difficilement compatible avec avec les
états unis
d'autant plus que le gouvernement d'evo
morales avait demandé à ceux l'aide nord
américaines sur certains programmes de
partir de la bolivie et les relations
étaient assez tendue mais il n'y a pas
de preuves il n'y a pas de preuve que je
sache un de l'implication de des états
unis mais je pense que les etats unis
ont vu de façon très favorable le
changement le changement du cours de
l'histoire
depuis depuis
le mois d'octobre cityville justement le
pivot est assez clair maintenant la
bolivie se tourner vers les états unis
et ses alliés et rompt ses liens avec
les pays de gauche tels que le venezuela
et le mexique en fait jeanine agnès
n'outrepasse rethel pas son mandat en
tant que présidente par intérim par
toutes ces actions
bien évidemment un madame agnès autre
passe tous ses droits
elle a été nommée pour faire la
transition pour mener à bien un
processus
disons exempt de tout de tout
récriminations de frauder et c'est donc
elle outrepasse ses droits et ses
prérogatives et les autres passent
d'autant plus que vendredi
elle a dit qu'elle s'est déclarée
candidate aux élections qui vont à lois
qui vont avoir lieu le 3 le 3 mai et ce
matin même et elle a demandé à son
gouvernement de démissionner parce que
l'opinion publique mais aussi les autres
partis politiques dans le mas mouvement
vers le socialisme d'evo morales
considéré que de rester présidente de la
république elle
à ce moment là il y avait quand même
disons d'une certaine façon d
une distorsion entre un centre le mandat
qu'elle a eu 2 2
de l'assemblée nationale et le fait de
réaliser une campagne électorale en
utilisant bien évidemment les le budget
en particulier et les médias de l'état
donc ce matin elle a démissionné merci
beaucoup
madame delfour je rappelle vous êtes
professeur des universités à
l'université de paris-est
marne-la-vallée spécialiste de
l'amérique latine et particulièrement de
la bolivie merci encore
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]